celebrities stop having plastic surgery
you don't look younger you don't look
better you just look weird when the
Beatles sang when I'm 64. they weren't
talking about having a face Mark
Madonna's Madonna doesn't look like a 64
year old woman because Madonna doesn't
look like a human being she looks like
what happens when you cross a lizard
with a lunchbox
she's gone from being one of the pop
icons of her generation to something you
show your kids when you want them to
behave why don't you little if you
don't come over and stop behaving I'm
going to get Madonna to come around to
your bedroom and take away your PS5 look
okay no one wants to be 64 and no one
wants to look 64. everyone wants to look
young enough to sing the song Like a
Virgin and for it to look sexy but that
isn't how life works if I sung like a
virgin in public I'll be arrested and
placed on the sex offenders register if
anything it's going to get me arrested
even quicker we all age and that's
absolutely fine remember the song goes
will you still need me will you still
feed me when I'm 64. not will you still
need me will you still feed me because
I've had so much plastic surgery I can't
move my face anymore